[Music]
another royal news Kate Middleton showed
off her baby bump and a pale green
spring maternity the outfit from
designer Jenny Packham she attended an
event promoting children's mental health
close to her due date kate is still
making public appearances sparking some
speculation that she is envious of the
attention Meghan Markel has received
Katie Nichol the author of hairy life
loss and love says put those royal
rumors to rest Kate's a very kind person
I know people are quite keen to set up a
feud and a rivalry between these two
young women that's not the Kate that
that I've met I think she's been behind
the scenes very supportive of Meghan the
royal wedding is less than two months
away but who is paying for the hefty
bill will be paid by Prince Charles and
de Morial family Megan's father Thomas
Marshall and mother Dory a rattlin are
not wealthy owner off the hook and a
Beatle breaks royal baby news Ringo
Starr learned his straight from Prince
William the delivery might be sooner
than we think I congratulated on the
next baby and any minute now the Prince
knighted Ringo who now bears the
official title Sir Richard Starkey the
event was broadcast by ITV News Paul
McCartney was knighted by the Queen 21
years ago last week Paul and I are
dinner in LA together and we were
talking about from Liverpool's up to
here you know it's like mad
[Music]